[музика]
я Оксана рубаняк позивний Ксена
військовослужбовиця підрозділу 72-ї
окремої механізованої бригади Моя
історія розпочалася 24 лютого коли я
вступила до добровольчого фарбування
івано-франківської територіальної
громади №3 яке почалося формуватися 24
лютого ми прибули там півтора місяці а
потім вже з хлопцями із 200 людей які
були в дфг 35 ми відправилися в
новостворений батальйон 72-ї бригади і
стали основою кулеметного взводу
життя до війни в мене було прекрасне я
навчалася працювала мала багато мрій та
планів навчалася у двох університетах
працювала в івано-франківській міській
раді у відділі молодіжної політики
департамент молодіжної політики та
спорту була заступницею голови
молодіжної ради івано-франківська окрім
навчання я вступила у 2021 році на
військову кафедру ця думка в мене була
завжди
колись в мене було мрія вступити в
військовий ліцей але не вийшло тому я
здійснила своє задуми пізніше Чому Так
це мої погляди були розуміли рано чи
пізно нам доведеться стикнутися з
більшою агресії Росії оскільки Мій
дядько був військовослужбовцем я знала
що таке війна і щоб готовою бути з нею
зіткнутися треба вміти щось мати навички
і знання я вважала що військова кафедра
мені їх дасть провчалась Я буквально там
півроку почалася війна на військовій
кафедри були тільки теоретичні знання
тому що практика вона здобувалася
пізніше А я в той момент вже була на
передку
я одна дівчина у своєму взводі більше
скажу чи не єдина в батальйоні яка
ходила за весь час свого перебування
справді на позиції кадровик Антон
колумбет запитує каже ти куди у медичну
частину чи до нас У штаб бо їм якраз там
треба було людина я на нього дивлюся
кажу Та ні я з хлопцем куда в кулеметний
взвод кажу так кулеметний звук проте я
не мала
уявлення взагалі як мені працювати з
тими кулеметами коли я сказала що у
кулеметним взвод на мене всі начальник
штабу мій командир він теж не очікував
що якби я піду з хлопцями так всі
дивляться на мене ну кажу кадровик добре
бо вони всі думали що я передумаю за ці
два тижні Ні Такого не було ми приїхали
в зону бойових дій і командир розподіляє
по позиціях прийшла одна ротація хлопці
повернулися пішли хлопці якби другі вже
на позиції повернулися і як би вже черги
та на позицію А в нас таке було міні
шикування Я стою чекаю свого прізвища і
не чую його коли я не почула свого
прізвища я йду до заступника командира
тоді це був отаман і каже мене командир
пустив на позиції але я не чула свого
прізвища Ми там складали списки
поміняйте мене він каже без проблем іде
замість Івана а Іван піде на наступну
повертацію Ну і наступний день ми якби
вечором пішли на позиції помінялися ми
мінялися В сутінках і Зранку десь там
Можливо в обід командир дізнається що
Оксана на позицію і таких було багато
ситуацій коли там наші позиції штурмують
треба або Треба підкріплення от оця
речення Я з хлопцями от від початку і до
кінця як ми з ними почали і так ми з
ними і до сьогоднішнього дня і це більше
наша така згуртованість більше
не розуміємо один одного Я би сказала що
ми як сім'я Франківська сім'я знову ж
таки
літом Минулого року підвах ми там
зайцеве заходить командир розвідки на
Київстар і
каже мені треба щось цього людей там на
розвідку А я якраз була на КСП кажу я
йду Ні ти не йдеш Оксана каже мені
командир мій Назар який шакк є така
добре І тут мої хлопці збиралися Я йду з
ними збиратися тут командир розвідки
заходить каже що ви готові А я стою кажу
так готові Я кажу мій командир дозволиш
Я теж іду Ми пішли якби все добре
прийшло завдання виконали повертаємося
назад і тоді ми приходимо жорстко
Морально я вислухала від командира дуже
багато речей але він зрозумів що я теж
можу іти з хлопцями і робити все що вони
і не наражає ніяких небезпеку тому що я
дівчина
Оскільки ми Стрілецький батальйон наше
завдання Оборонна
Оборонна лінія оборони наших позицій
хочу пояснити як взагалі
працювати з кулеметом працює розрахунок
який складається з двох-трьох людей якщо
це ДШК достатньо двох людей тому що вона
легше в обслуговування вона в принципі
легше 40 кг
браунінг воно він важить 60 кг тому що
там є Тринога така доволі важка 20 кг є
там двоє людей які доносять до Шика до
позиції обладнуємо позицію копаємо
зверху ці брови накладемо глиною і так
дальше тобто укріплюємо позицію і робимо
резервну браунінг Така сама ситуація
тільки там треба троє людей
доносити до позиції обладнюєте складаєте
кулемет і починаєте працювати
все дякую за Так відбувається тобто тому
що часто чую в свою адресу претензії А
як вона зносить той кулемет Він ж такий
складний і він такий важкий
наша робота складається в обороні тому в
нас є свої стабільні позиції Звісно що
не без того що ми міняємо їх через
обстріли через то що працюють по нашій
вогневій позиції Якщо б я була
штурмовиком напевно я б не була
кулеметником тому що його потрібно
носити і кілометр 10 і 15 і так далі а
це вага
за весь час служби ми були під бахмутом
маринський напрямок та вугледарський
напрямок коли наступали на Бахмут ми оце
були нулем на якій наступають і саме
тоді ми стикнулися з вагнером це наше
перше бойове завдання бойовий виїзд Наша
перша лінія оборони як новоствореного
батальйону і зразу магнеро скажу що це
дійсно найбільш професійні бійці
російської армії
найбільш не врівноважені я би сказала і
ті які йдуть справді до кінця тому що
була ситуація бій люди Важко назвати їх
людьми Вагнера вони йшли без касових
жилетів РПС з
набоями і автомат все і вони йдуть на
брелок Звісно що відбувається
Стрілецький бій там хто йде перший його
вбивають він падає і той хто йде другий
він не відходить він іде дальше напролом
і це вони переступали один через одного
це не Здорово психічну істоту я би
сказала так або ці істоти під чимось
13 березня 2023 року я отримала
поранення біля населеного пункту
Вугледар один осколок в голову один у
плече і троє в спину на щастя в голову
не потрапило це було закалом потилишнє
кістки зі зміщенням середини за пів
головного мозку другого ступеня один не
вийняли зі спини залишився досі там я
встигла він вернутися і одразу своє
почула це пекучий біль у спину і
головний біль дуже сильний дезоріцію
просторі у мене зразу помутніло в очах і
за голову я подумала що в мене просто
контузія у мене попередньо вони були
Тому це було все то саме тільки значно
більших розмірах і фінт піднімає шапку
там кров Я відчуваю як кров потекла
просто по шиї і він каже що там
поранення вони тоже почали обмотувати
голову ви закликали по рації Вак машини
питає побратим каже можеш іти щоб ми
тебе доставили до машини Кажу можу раз
два перший крок другий крок Я просто
вирубаюся втрачаю свідомість і приходжу
до тями уже у машині коли там кажуть
Оксана Оксана якби прийде до тями А в
мене таке Було відчуття ніби я спала І
оце прикинулась мені так добре було я
старшу думаю це сон такі реалістичні
соломи не було а я нічого не бачу тому
що
осколок він потрапив у потиличну частину
так якби перунки скипилась мені частини
і зразу за нею знаходиться відділення
мозку яке відповідає за зір і буквально
там дві години Я взагалі нічого не
бачила переді мною була чорна
стіна Вони переживають щоб я знову не
тратила свідомість кажуть Давай говори
щось ну це явно не той момент коли мені
щось хотілося говорити Я кажу що
говорити я він каже співаю не вмію
співати ну розказуй щось щось а перед
цим Я якраз моєму побратимові фініту
розказувала вірш Шевченка всякого своя
доля Ну і починаю розказувати вірш У
всякого своя доля і свій шлях широкий
вони послухали каже Молодець Давай далі
а я розказую і в мене сльози ллються
зараз я знаходжуся на реабілітації і на
наступний тиждень вже повертаюся до
своїх хлопців Це частинка мене вже от
хлопці мої це частинка мене я до них
дуже звикла ми як сім'я ми стільки
всього пройшли дійсно як бачила мене
моїх хлопців особливо ті які були під
час поранення не бачу мене ніхто в тій
ситуації які ми з ними переживали ні з
ким я не переживала і Надіюся більше не
буду переживати
з людьми з якими ти знаходяться на грані
смерті вони собі стають акрильним
насправді
тому навіть рівні Я кажу що вони не такі
мені близькі як мої хлопці рідні
змирилися з усім Що відбувається в моєму
житті спершу Вони не знали що я
відправилася на фронт вони дізналися два
місяці після коли почалося з'являтися
щось в Інтернеті про мене у відповіді
почула ну Тримайся там до перемоги і в
принципі Наша розмова тоді закінчилася
тому що вони розуміють де я не можу
сильно говорити зараз Вони теж дуже би
хотіли щоб моя служба закінчилась як і
будь-які батьки особливо після поранення
не скажу чим швидше ви приймете те що я
повернемося до своїх хлопців ти легше
вам буде
до війни я навчалася в коледжі на
вчителя початкових класів та в
університеті на заочній формі на
філолога от саме під час реабілітації
закривала дві сесії досить успішно Коли
я була на фронті приходила з позиції
забирала нашого діловода ноутбук казала
все в мене сесія Мені треба поздавати
там Я сама Верховинка з Верховинського
району гуцулка і в мене там неймовірні
краєвиди я казала коли ми їхали там по
дорозі на сході і бачила трикон і кажу я
проміняла свої гори на террикони хоча
справді Нічого я не поміняла це так
життя заставила
позивний обрав мій побратим брат Олег
колір який загинув ні в кого в голові
нічого нормального не виходить то
Роксолана то там русалка то ще щось я
кажу може Гуцулка Ксеня
нє Олег каже довго два слова довго
казати Ну добре думаємо думаємо думаємо
він каже Ксена Я кажу Ксеня він каже Ні
Ксена А хто така Ксена я в житті не
дивилася того фільму
і він каже не подивися подивилася за що
я в тікток у нас тоді ще була мережа
одна хвилина хто така Ксена кажу то хай
буде ніби нормально виглядає нормально я
досі не дивилася фільм мої не хочу
знаходжу себе розчаровувати деякій мірі
Ксена так все на принцеса воїн хлопці
кажуть що підходить І тепер переконалися
що дійсно моє
в мене немає такої риси гордитися з
собою Я розумію що в деяких моментах є
Молодець що є вчинила так А в деяких
моментах Звісно що свідомість мені
підказує що не з наслідками я буду
боротися ще довго зараз наслідки
вилізають і зі здоров'ям але я вчинила
Так бо вважаю що повинна була так
зробити і зараз вважає повинно повинна
вернутися також на фронт до хлопців Я би
не вчинила по-іншому коли за мене
пишаються мої хлопці це для мене більше
Похвала ніж за все Коли я бачу не по
розмовам а по очам що от вони дивляться
і вони
не розуміють що я б могла бути не з ними
але я з ними така гордість у них за мене
зараз мені 20 років на Схід я
відправилася в 19 а своє 20-річчя
зустрічала на фронті всі мене вітають
тому що приїхали та вітати Я думала
привітаю це все я кажу Ну добре дякую
їдьте звідси щоб вас зараз пташка не
побачила Ми кажемо Ну вони кажуть Ми без
тебе не поїдемо я заходжу і по дві лінії
про мене стоять хлопці навпроти мене
командир щось тримає в руках і вони всі
там вітаємо кажуть всі гучно разом я
дуже хотіла пістолет форт-17 і якраз
командир мені його придбав Це був
подарунок від нього такий Я звісно що
тішуся радію тут Стас виносить 100 дву
троянду Я не знаю де вони взяли напевно
з Дніпра привезли
вручає мені я така радісна стою і в цей
момент мені щось командир заговорює зуби
астел спиртом дверцята тобто ось це він
мій був день народження 20 років справді
незабутнім я не думаю що я його забуду
до кінця свого життя
зараз я вже повертаюся з декількох
причин Звісно що одна Це мої хлопці але
все ж таки я
впевнена що ця боротьба буде довгою і ми
ще довго
воюватимемо перемога настане так скоро
якби нам хотілося тому я не маю права
просто зійти з дистанції зараз адже
боротьба Вона досить довготривала І я б
хотіла після війни дай Бог вона
закінчиться в швидкому часі жити в
мирній країні де не обстрілюють міста і
де немає війни і щоб мої діти якщо
я не знаю Просто якщо я виживу і мої
діти щоб вони не воювали вже знову ж
таки з Росією я дуже хотіла щоб ця
боротьба закінчилася саме На моєму
поколінні
ти там постійно в небезпеці кожного дня
кожної секунди я розумію що наступної
секунди може прилетіти і там мене вбити
наступного бою мене можуть просто бити і
так далі дуже багато
[музика]
планів які були тих Планів немає мрії я
не мрію нічого не очікую не вірю людям
але під час війни Ми з побратимами таку
собі ціль поставили я дуже хочу побачити
полярне сяйво і з деякими побратимами ми
домовилися що після перемоги ми
обов'язково поїдемо і побачимо його Тому
перше завдання - це вижити друге це
перемогти
[музика]